fans are super excited about your album
in pieces coming out tomorrow so I just
want to talk to you about this what's
the overarching theme what's the message
that you're trying to get across with
this album
the overall message that I'm trying to
get across from this album is that we
don't have to have all of ourselves
together it's okay
when we fall but as long as we get back
up and it's okay if people see that
we're in pieces but as long as we put
ourselves back together that's all that
matters and that's really what this
album represents for me and I hope it
will for a lot of people
okay and and you doing this album on
your own without your sister did it feel
like you had to kind of start from
scratch or how did you feel going into
this process
I definitely felt very scared and
nervous and there were moments where I
even doubted my own abilities and even
questioned my voice and things like that
but one thing that kind of kept me
staying confident through it all was my
love for music and how technical
I get when it comes to producing and
Engineering so that I've always had
confidence in so I knew as long as I
just kept my head down and kept working
and and doing what I knew that I was
good at from a technical side then my
confidence I could find through
everything else with my voice or the
Performing or things like that so I just
had to really focus on the art aspect of
it to kind of stay out of my head and
not let not let my fear judge
or you know affect the art
you know they usually say that fear is
actually a bigger obstacle than the
obstacle itself so yeah I love to hear
you say that and speaking of you
producing and Engineering on this album
which may I add not many artists do why
is it so important for you to have that
creative freedom and that control
well I have a lot of creative ideas in
my head and and it's easier for me to
actually execute them than to waste time
verbally explaining and it all started
when I grew up in Atlanta and we wanted
to become musicians and artists but
there were no producers and songwriters
who would write for little girls like us
growing up at the time so it really
forced us to learn how to write our own
songs and in turn me also learning how
to produce and make beats and it's like
my love of math and science and
technology and music all merges into one
and I just create until the wheels fall
off and sometimes I'll it'll be a great
product sometimes it won't be that great
one day but as long as I just use myself
as a vessel that's when I feel the most
free
um okay well speaking of creativity I
was watching the music video for prayed
away you got to tell me how long did it
take to light all those candles because
there was a crazy amount of candles in
there there were crazy amount of candles
in there thank God I didn't do that I
was in hair and makeup but half of them
were real candles and half of them were
LED you know for safety reasons but the
ones closer to me were real so I had to
definitely be careful of the silk mini
train that I had so I wouldn't catch on
fire
that would not matter yeah like we knew
we were hot but like not not literally
so
that was that was good that was good
yeah I got you I got you
you're signed to Beyonce's Entertainment
Company Parkwood entertainment
first of all it's amazing what's it like
having queen bee in your corner
it's a huge it feels like a huge warm
hug
I've always been inspired by her since I
was a little girl and to be able to pick
her brain and get her advice on certain
things it's really really cool and I
still have my fangirl moments for sure I
just really love her and I appreciate
her for taking a chance on CIS and I
now what what is Beyonce like behind the
scenes like what is the best piece of
advice that she's given you that you've
taken into your own career what she's
like behind the scenes she's like a big
ball of light and beauty and you can't
stop staring at her and for me even her
just leading by example how she runs her
business and she juggles that while she
creates her music that's always been
inspiring for me as well so being able
to see that first hand is pretty darn
cool
where does a collaboration with Beyonce
rank on your your bucket list of things
to accomplish as an artist oh top of the
bucket list I feel like that's any and
everybody you know so I would love to
have that one day yeah yeah so you're
you're embarking on your headlining tour
and we all know that you can Bust A Move
okay I saw you in the knee pads the
other day all right uh how much sweat
has gone into preparing for this tour
when it comes to choreography dance sets
oh you don't even want to know
and I sweat when I started dancing
around it gets hot so you don't even
want to know and then
I will be in certain body suits or latex
or Sparkles and Under The Lights that's
a lot of calories I'm burning each night
but I'm really excited because I'm gonna
get really snatched for tour and it's so
much fun I have the best team ever we
are rolling out an album at the same
time as we are putting together a tour
it's a lot but my dreams have been
coming true and I get to perform this
record to the fans and we get to connect
with it together and I'm so excited to
see everyone so it's going to be really
really special and I hope I see you at
rebel I was gonna say I will be I will
be at Rebel so I'm looking forward to
these dance numbers maybe I'll get up
there and dance with you if you see me
in the crowd pull me up yes I will it'll
be a party all right all right and we
all know that you can dance but we know
that you can sing
um I gotta ask you on those show days
because you're about to go on tour are
you the type that just doesn't speak to
anyone to prep your voice I recently
talked to Shania Twain she told me that
she only drinks liquids on show days do
you do anything like that to prepare
your voice for these shows oh wow well
did she give you any more advice because
I'd love to know she has she says she
says eat fries as much as possible
they're the best type of nutrition
that's what she says
you're funny but for me
because I'm rolling out an album I have
to talk but I've definitely been warming
up anytime I have to sing definitely
lots of tea I definitely have to pay
attention to the weather because allergy
season here in La has been outrageous
and my allergies are insane so I'm just
going to make sure I'm equipped with my
scarves all my vocal stuff everything on
the road so I'll be good to go
you guys get you guys get allergy
weather out there in L.A I thought it
was just hot and Free Living oh yeah oh
yeah
them saying it never rains in southern
California is a myth now because it's
been raining like so hard for the past
two weeks everyone's allergies have been
insane okay just wait till you come to
Canada and that snow hits you right in
the face yeah but the air there is so
clear and like and clean
you're right you're right so hey maybe
my voice will do a little bit better at
Rebel I'm looking forward to I'm telling
you I will be there so I'm gonna hold
you to it
so one thing I love about you is that
you continue to act along with your
music career just absolutely taking off
so swarm a hit
um but you know I gotta ask you what was
your reaction to that Viral moment that
everyone went crazy about it blew up the
internet per se I was laughing about it
I am really proud of my performance in
that show and being on set with such
incredible actors like damson and
Dominique and being directed by Donald
Glover and being on set with the likes
of Malia Obama and Janine and everybody
it I learned so much being on that set
and I also learned that it's okay to be
imperfect as an actor because that's
where the realness lies we're not
supposed to play like this perfect built
perfectly built human being because that
doesn't exist in the real world so when
I let that go acting became an even
deeper love for me and I was just acting
and and nobody saw anything they haven't
seen for me
and yeah so it kind of made me laugh
yeah no I'm pretty sure you've got to
laugh about it honestly I think too
often people see child stars like
yourself and they forget that they grow
up too so does it frustrate you that
some people see you as like that girl
instead of the woman that you've become
no it doesn't frustrate me anymore
because I have so many other things to
think about as
than to waste my time thinking about how
people perceive me you know before it
used to bother me but now I'm like I got
so much to worry about I got told to
worry about I got a baby kitten I have
to train
you got too much on your plate he is all
over the place so I have too much to
worry about so how people receive me is
how they receive me and I don't feel any
negative way towards them I love it I
love it is that the reason I read that
you deleted Twitter did you is it still
deleted is that something that you did
just because you wanted to yeah when you
see me tweeting shout out I still have
the best team whenever you see me
tweeting is because I'll say oh tweet
this for me or I'll be like send me any
viral tweets or things you think I
should respond to or you know I'd want
to send it my way because I won't see it
because I love all social media and I
love Twitter as well but that's where
you can see all the negative
things about you directly right in your
face if I see my name trending I click
on it I'd see a whole plethora of like
negative tweets about myself and I don't
I don't need to do that to myself I feel
that when you continue to be fed the
same
thing you'll start to believe it and I
started changing myself based off of
what I thought people's opinions were of
me and that's not okay and I just let it
go so I'm still actively all the time on
Instagram yeah I see it I see it
so because I still love communicating
with the fans so I talk to them a lot in
our chats on Discord the little nerdin
so I love Discord I like Discord a lot
that's good for yoga that's a great
mentality I love that mentality
um so much negativity around social
media it's good that you just removed
yourself from it but on a more positive
note I gotta talk to you and Holly you
guys must be so happy for each other in
each of your individual successes what
was it like for you to see her on the
screen for a Little Mermaid
screaming
your voice when I saw her beautiful face
and I just know she's about to blow it
out the water no pun intended
and I
I'm her
this the other day like God has been so
good to us because our dreams are coming
true simultaneously and I even reminded
her of the stream she had years and
years ago when she we were like 14 15 16
and she was like Chloe I had a dream
where we were like in our 20 early 20s
and we looked so much cooler and we were
so much cooler than we are now and we
were like killing it so I reminded her I
was like remember you told me that dream
years ago I was like it's coming true
so it's really crazy I'm so proud of her
I I'm proud of myself I'm proud of us
together collectively and I just pray to
God that we continue to do what we love
and be successful from it
did you did you see the reaction video
of all the parents showing their kids
The Little Mermaid trailer all their
young daughters who were also colored
you know and then all their reactions I
did and it was like the most wholesome
thing I've ever seen I've got to say and
to know that
her being Ariel is inspiring kids all
over the world to be comfortable being
whatever they want to be no matter what
the world tells them
that is such a blessing and I'm so proud
of her
yeah honestly you two are just killing
it and you're just icons and you're just
great role models so it was an honor to
be able to talk to you today thank you
so much that's all my time but thank you
for your time yeah congratulations
congratulations on everything
congratulations on the show
congratulations on the album and I hope
you have a great tour I'll see you in
Toronto at Rebels you will I'm gonna
kill it you're gonna kill it I hope so
all right thank you so much Gloria bye